yo yo yo boo lakehead podcast
bullet calf show uh live in atlanta man
with earth gang
what's up what's up what's poppy y'all
uh just want to shout y'all out man
because i feel like um
i was just telling you before the
interview started like this record with
wale i feel like is
you know you guys have put out amazing
records before i'm i'm a real fan of
what y'all do
but like when i heard this song i was
like interscope got a real
like radio record to work like this
could be like a real hit record for you
appreciate that man yeah man
you know it's just it's just one of
those records where we like to always
give the people something that they can
you know i'm saying live with you know
saying like outside the homes
outside the headphones you know what i'm
saying like this
we'll just create music where people
could like move around and do life too
you know yeah even in the pandemic when
everybody inside and stuff but it's like
you know we need that energy to you know
everybody don't need to be sitting down
the whole time and [ __ ]
no for sure i think like also you guys
and you
you know you mentioned the pandemic like
thank you for for you know
the contributions to the spillage
village album because uh yeah
thank you bro yeah that was uh much
needed last year
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was a good vibe
man it was a good good time to make it
to the
time yeah you know for people who don't
uh kind of know i kind of look at you
guys as like um
it's like kind of like the closest thing
to what we have the dungeon family in
2020 2021 you know
yeah and i know you guys have been
rocking for a long time a lot of people
think that that's like the first project
but you guys have other projects
yeah yeah yeah like marie was fire
um obviously you know jid black
kind of co you know i spoke with jid a
bit about
um kind of his roots with spillage
village and like
his early roots with mariba and um and
black um but how did you guys all form
the collective like like initially
because like i said it's
got an energy that is very reminiscent
of
you know some of the 90s hip-hop
collectives you know like some native
tongue [ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah i mean initially it was just us jit
and uh
and well and this is just usg and and
hollywood jb like initially because we
all went to school together
and then uh once we all got out of
school came back to atlanta
we didn't really know what to do with
ourselves much other than keep hanging
out you know what i'm saying keep
hanging out and making music so
then we we laid down with marie because
who we met while we was in school and
she was still living here
she started coming over more naturally
it's like black
you know what i'm saying hollywood jb
brought his brother jordan
and and then christo who is jizz
producer and dj bro his brother benji
right it was all just like we're
actually just hanging out together all
the time anyway just making music all
the time anyway and then i was like what
are we going
what do we call this it's like a village
bros and we keep caught each other
spilling villages because
the ideas just kept coming out that's
all we ever did we got together
yeah it's crazy too because i don't
think like people really you know
black kind of had a a meteoric rise
in the last three or four years you know
and i don't think people really kind of
um
understand like his roots uh in in this
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and even just
like his talent is like an emcee
you know what i mean like he could wrap
his [ __ ] ass up
yeah like was that something like
because i i remember when his [ __ ]
started to kind of initially take off on
soundcloud
um and there was like a lot of mystery
behind it but you guys being around him
early on did you guys kind of always
feel like
like he was a star it was just a matter
of time yeah he was just super focused
you know what i'm saying when i first we
first met black i remember him talking
about
like deals he got in and out of in high
school like really in high school he
definitely wasn't talking about no deals
wow like i mean you know he just had he
had a
a different exposure to the game that we
could that we all learned from you know
i think part of what has made spillville
so great because along this time
we all have learned stuff from each
other you know i'm saying we've all like
taken a little like humorous stuff from
jed or like you know what i'm saying
certainly like vocal cues that oh losers
then we we've all learned that i
remember i learned from black
um black used to when he first would do
his melodies
he would have the mic super turned up
super high and be saying them very
softly so he would be sleeping in the
living room
and wake up in the middle of the night
or make him in the middle of the day and
just be recording i'm like what are you
doing over there i didn't know he was
actually making stuff
and then he'll play it and be like okay
wow that's a cool technique so he was
always like picking up on each other
techniques like
the whole time he's like all living in
the same house that's an interesting
recording technique it's almost like you
could kind of be like off off in the
corner locally
definitely just turning up your levels
like crazy you have everything turned up
on his end and he's just being wow
and then by the time he would play it
for us like like yo you just did that
like when while he's over here like you
guys are playing too okay
whatever we didn't even hear him doing
we look back that's fine
yeah that's that's crazy man i do think
like that one of my favorite
moments of last year was your guys's
tiny desk show i thought that was like
oh yeah
i thought that was [ __ ] special
especially like like a mile away oh
really okay yeah man that was a i feel
like those tiny desk
shows are are so important and when
they're done right they're like
game changers because i think it really
kind of shows
like you it's almost like it takes out
any theatrics it's like you
and you gotta be dope or you ain't dope
you know what i mean
colors did that for us too i remember
the colors you guys did a couple years
ago yep when you get a chance before i'm
live it usually works well first
yeah i was telling him i met you guys
originally in tampa um
i don't remember what show it was but it
was before you guys were officially
signed to dreamville
i don't remember who who all did you
guys open for earlier i think it was
the two how to ride john probably yeah
it was probably
did you you guys never opened for
walleye okay cause i remember going to a
wale show but yeah
it was um i remember meeting you guys um
like at the merch table and you guys
were so like
and at that time i think i had really
just kind of heard your guys [ __ ] off
like two dope boys and like
all the blog [ __ ] and and um i really
hadn't even like dived in
like like all the way yeah but um
you guys have put together like a really
dope run over the last like five or six
years
um just quality music and
with this new record with wale i feel
like it's kind of like the icing on the
cake you know what i'm saying like
like everything's worked to this point
yeah yeah you guys you guys are known
obviously you guys have
you know a very hardcore fan base but
like i feel like now it's time for like
the world to get let in
on earth game you know what i mean yeah
for sure for sure we put in that grind
working even like
even with just the wallet record or the
grammy nominations and like
you know what i'm saying the accolades
and they're getting seen like recognized
doing shows over in new zealand and
stuff
it's like we put in all this groundwork
over the past few years you know what
i'm saying too well like we had a fan
base
that made these moments possible you
know what i'm saying like it's not no
industry plan type stuff we're not
you know saying these this automatically
open the doors for these guys it's like
they prove they work
you know yeah you guys got it from the
mud man yeah and it's you know it's
crazy too did you do you guys ever feel
like
with your name earth gang like you guys
had to win people
people over a bit because i felt like
when i heard the name earth gang i was
like
i was kind of like a bit like okay what
is this
is this like these are they rapping
about recycling or some [ __ ] like
you know how many times people said that
in the beginning bro that was like a
very common joke which now
now which we played on anymore back then
but we mean we do we do
obviously care about the environment but
that wasn't like the focus of what right
name was
you know i said but that's dope to see
like that how many like
how at first that that was like the
thing like what is everything now like
we go to shows people don't care yeah no
they want they say they are earth gang
you know what i'm saying like now the
fans are
like everybody everybody go people own
it for themselves like i'm earth gang
too
i'm earth gang too you know yeah i mean
[ __ ] the name of the group is this we're
all on earth and we [ __ ]
facts so um mirrorland came out was dope
um
your guys is like official debut album
uh the spillage village project was real
special
um now we got the wale single i'm
assuming that uh well first of all how
close are you guys
done um with this album and and like
like you know how many songs are we
looking at
we're pretty close we're not 100 percent
finished but we pretty close and um
i say give or take like maybe like round
12 or something
okay that's a nice one that's a nice
number yeah and and then you know
obviously you got wallet on the project
yeah young thug on the last project
you know um is there going to be any
dreamville brethren on this
album it's in the worst like we just got
a whole lot of records we're still
polishing that's something
we see let's see who fits where we try
to get the meat of the project
down which is definitely done you know
what i'm saying like the the bulk of the
bulk of the idea is done the concept is
beautiful i'm really excited for it
right right right i just we gotta
[Music]
who was um first to sign with dreamville
was it and i'm
i don't call him jid because i called
him jade in person once and he was like
i don't know you like that you you gotta
call me
like was it you guys are was a jid first
we saw around the same time actually
okay uh when uh when when cole
nicole met us in person
at the uh absolute tour is it the new
york day
and uh we we actually were opening for
for seoul and jill at the time was um
he was my roommate so i ain't gonna you
know say we first got the offer from
absol
to go on tour he's my roommate that's
like my boy my brother
we made hello songs together i ain't
gonna do just earth gang on the tour
without him and just leave him there so
he was like hey bro
come on tour with us he he so he we we
split our set with him
just on something like bruh just on some
homie [ __ ] on some brother [ __ ] bro we
not gonna
we without even like clearing it with
absolutely like look we got the homie
coming in
nobody that's [ __ ] put up with him
he's like now bro we're gonna split this
like we're gonna get this shiny you
don't get this shine
you did and uh when cole met us he was
like that was cool man
who's the other dude show he's like
that's all brother jesus so he's like
man all y'all coming in so
we all would literally pile up in the
car together because i said he was
roommates
so we get up in the car together and
travel to north carolina together and we
just all spent time with coal and he was
like man so what's your situation
looking like
and then he was like we ain't got
nothing so he just signed us all around
the same time
he it just so happened we jit had had
never stole it ready almost as soon as
he got signed so wow so he was ready
yeah he put that out and then we put out
the eps and then our album
subsequently yo it's crazy because
like i feel like cole's been so careful
about who he brings onto the team and
there's so much artistic integrity
on that roster and you know i feel like
coal could sign anybody
like he could probably at this point you
know he literally go out and probably
sign you know any of the bubbling up and
coming rappers like
but i feel like he he cares so much
about that the brand of dreamville and
like
just the integrity of the music that
comes out of that you know what i'm
saying like he won't make
you want to make foreign cars man he's
going to make excited right
here because over here right and like
some exotics you wouldn't like you know
that
yeah that's when cranking out no force
right right right um
talk about you know obviously you you
guys got the grammy nomination for
revenge of the dreamers um
three which was uh you know i i told eve
this like you know the fact that he was
able to craft
such a um amazing
amazingly sequenced body of work because
he you know
was was like letting me know about kind
of um
how many songs he had to choose from and
then just the way they
they flowed and it was like it felt like
i know and i know all the sessions were
scattered but it really felt like
everybody was kicking it in the studio
together and y'all made like a cohesive
body of work
um share with me um some of your
favorite moments about those sessions
because
you know we hear about how legendary
they were everybody was getting flown
out like you know
i just always think back to how special
of a moment that was to have the baby on
that record with cole like
you know what i mean so yeah yeah talk
about those sessions for um revenge of
the dreamers three and like some some
memories you have from him
i mean it really was just the
camaraderie you know saying like
the creativity and the camaraderie all
in one space from like
people all across the industry people
you just you know i'm saying you ain't
never met them but you see them shining
and stuff and it's like
when y'all get into the same place it's
just love i'm saying like it ain't
really like
how many followers you got oh you ain't
got that man you can't be on this song
type of energy you know what i'm saying
so like that that we let that
block the creativity and the energy that
was going through the room and through
the building so
to me that's like my favorite aspect of
it yeah it was cool when some legends
put it
to like ross pulled up they kind of put
like some people that wasn't even on
they were just legendary people that was
in atlanta at the time and they came
through to like
to be a part of the session i feel like
the greater part of
the bucks roster put it up like the
milwaukee bucks they was in town giannis
was there yeah yeah
so giannis pulled up for the oh you know
who pulled up surprised the hell out of
me
uh what's brother name used to play for
miami and he's playing he from canada
uh miami from canada i don't know i
can't think of his name right now but
he used to play back for miami he's
super tall bro he he
he's part of lebron's championship down
there
center bro his bro name bro i'm tripping
right now because i'm high
canadian player used to be uh he's
sitting right next to me bro
oh pull up the miami heat roster oh he's
talking about um
20 2013 might have hit russia he talked
about chris bob
okay yeah i didn't want to say not from
canada yeah i was about to say he played
in toronto
in the room he in the small room the
smallest of the studio rooms two two two
he was in there
it's already like it's crowded when one
[ __ ] walk in there it's probably like
wrong smaller than this it's probably
like five six [ __ ] in there
and he's a he's like seven feet tall
seven feet tall he's sitting in the
corner
folded up with his laptop in his lap
making beats and i'm like chris bosh was
making beats
bruh i'll go in there and i'm like i
seen him at first but he in the corner
so tucked up like like behind some like
financially i'm like
i didn't even really see him when it
does open you don't even see him because
he turned up and i was like yo
i looking like this [ __ ] like this
[ __ ] actually he's a huge person you
know like what you oh that's chris boss
i'm like
like yo this [ __ ] like yeah you know
i'll be cooking up whatever he's in
there making videos anybody was just
coming just to feel that vibe
of just the creativity in the room you
know what's crazy is uh
well first of all how was how was chris
bosh's beats
i felt like it was pretty important i
feel like i feel like i feel like i was
pleasantly surprised like i feel like i
gave him one of these like
yeah fire yeah and then giannis being
there i didn't even know that giannis
was like a hip-hop
he's from greece so i don't know you
know like the whole team pulled it up
in the locker room i'm playing
he pretty damn good yeah and i feel like
i feel like
because of cole being with cole is so
many [ __ ] in the league just respect
cole
of course and plus like he could low key
make an nba roster
yeah i hear like he's like he'd be
hooping
he's always training with that what's
the uh the dude the the the
the trainer in new york could be
training all the nba players
and then his first couple of projects
was like basketball yeah they were all
bastard
he had a basketball on the train
that's definitely all part of the vibe
no 100 yeah
did dennis smith jr pull up i know he's
he's real close with cool he pulled up
to them
he's pulled up to the house a bunch of
times like he's been watching black
mirror with him
black bears yeah that's a trick man
that's the truth how have you guys um
obviously besides
working your asses off like you know
just being at home and [ __ ] how have you
guys deal
like double i mean atlanta's wide open
but you know
how have you guys kind of dealt with
just like just the way the world has
kind of changed in the last nine months
i mean it's helped me focus a whole lot
more
yeah me too man i thought i was focused
back then but like
it's like real focus here you know i'm
saying i appreciate it
i mean of course you want to go out and
have fun and like do [ __ ] but like
you gotta protect your health you have
to take your family health for like
in the meantime get you some more money
yeah i think that um
for me like like you said i feel like my
focus became like
like like lasered in you know it's like
the people kind of took this thing two
different ways i feel like a lot of
people kind of use it as an excuse to
to be hella lazy now mind you i did i
have gotten fat during the pandemic
that being said happens um i feel like
it just kind of focused my hustle
and and it just kind of makes you
rethink everything
yeah you know what i mean like every
like like you know important to you yeah
what's really important man and then you
know it obviously kind of just
reinstills your bond with your family
you know you weren't you know especially
i'm out in l.a so i'm around my kids a
lot more and that's funny
yeah you guys got kids i got a son i got
one son how was your son
three three oh yeah that's you know they
call it terrible twos but it's really
terrible threes
man three-year-olds are he did a [ __ ]
turnt
kick today that i was like both
impressed with and a little like
what what's happening yeah you like
trying to
kick through a glass door like bro you
don't even realize what that would do if
you actually had the strength
right yeah crazy you guys um
you guys are both vegan correct uh not
vegan pescatarian pescatarian yeah
i want to interview you guys with my
homegirl ashley where you guys are she
said you guys were vegan
i don't think that's true we probably
ate some vegan food oh
you guys are pescataria are you you're
pescetarian are you pescetarian that i
mean
i respect that i like fish hey man like
when i'm out of the country i i eat some
meat you know
whatever i know it's raised right kill
rice out here it's [ __ ] up it's pink
slime
it's whatever yeah whatever
yo if you watch the video of like like
any videos of like how they make like
hamburger meat it'll make you like
never want to eat burger in america like
five years easily easily have y'all ever
seen a video how to make chicken nuggets
nah look at that it's everywhere on the
internet you don't it's gonna it'll [ __ ]
you up
they just put everything in and just
grind it ground it up they basically
take so they get a bunch of baby chicks
they flip them like this if you're
female you go somewhere to go be
you start making eggs they raise you up
paying you up if you mail they put them
in like this huge bin
and turn the blender on alive chicks
baby chicks bro
and that's chicken nuggets then whatever
now i know that's everybody's chicken
nugget but that's at least some of that
comes out to be some nuggets
oh damn yeah i couldn't give up that i
think if i had if i could ever
get to that point i could i could never
give up fish though yeah fish is rocking
sushi
lobsters crab i mean you know those are
the things
um so do you guys have an album title
for
for the album yet can you share it is it
already out there okay
come in though it's coming yeah any idea
um like when the album's gonna come out
before the summer yeah all right so okay
so sometime in the next
oh at summertime all right when it get
hot yeah
is it with more sunlight that i'm going
to reveal this stuff since you guys are
such close friends with jed can you
is there what's what's going on with him
like are we gonna yeah i'm out of joint
next week
oh oh [ __ ] there we go he he makes me
right now
okay yeah we need that yo the whole crew
is active
super active yeah i appreciate that um
and i'm curious too being from atlanta
um on jay playing but that yeah
[Laughter]
left he's an alien bro like a real like
like he's like one of them ones
that's like you know a jedi with that
with the with the rapping bro he's
wrapping his [ __ ] ass off man like i
wanted to uh so
for the first this is my first time at
atlanta and um
i had to go to magic city to try the hot
wings and i was i was extremely
disappointed
really yeah the wings were not uh you
really supposed to get the lemon pepper
of course that's what i got though i got
mike said i was tripping though he said
blue flames way better oh fun thing
the flame better number one number two
when i hear people getting magic city
food i don't really hear him get the
wings so much i didn't get like
everything else on that menu before
i got fried lobster tail that was fire
okay that was it that was smacking but
the wings were just
if you want wings in atlanta you gotta
hit the little corner spots bro you
gotta hit you like a little hood spider
you ever been to dc you know they have
you having like a little
carryout so you get like the best
chicken the best mama sauce is the same
thing is here except we got like real
ass hot wings
yeah i was gonna say you guys don't
strike me as like the biggest
strip club connoisseurs but that's what
you tripping too i'm tripping
because i'm so atlanta okay so what's
what's
what is like the top three
um for booty let's start with booty and
then we'll go food
a little my favorite okay um pretty face
magic city
and uh blue flying okay allure i've
heard of laura someone told me strokers
struggles out
east yeah jaren benton is a sick [ __ ]
and took me to the claremont lounge
wow it's not that's not what it is
anymore it's been ginger fire it's like
that's like
like a star hotel yeah
no he did it on purpose he was like yo
i'm gonna take you to the spot it's
[ __ ] crazy bro
he's like dude it's so lit he's like he
was like just come with me for 20
minutes and that's funny
bro because senior citizen dancers
that's crazy yeah that's that's
why you know a little laura got like the
best looking girls you gonna see but
like thank you
okay what about food strictly food
we gotta go to cheetahs someone someone
told me the cheetah [ __ ] like a fossil
and the girls are like just slowly like
that photoshoot
michigan and it was kind of like that
we'd be going to auto strip but we'll be
on tour
we are i probably could make a really
encyclopedia script
oh nice i gotta put you on there's one
in phoenix called jaguars that
jaguars yeah it's it's um i think i
heard i played
i passed by when i was in phoenix the
last time
it's legendary i've been i mean now that
i've been to atlanta you know i've been
to miami i've been
all over it because i ain't i ain't
going to hold you there
i've been to some in houston uh and
dallas
no miami tootsies is my favorite yeah
tootsies is like
when my son was born oh [ __ ] like i was
about to
hospital covered in glitter also
tootsie's got that has great food
they do yeah they got great fried fried
lobster tail with the seafood rice
yeah definitely a vibe yeah yeah i heard
that the lamb chops at the cheetah are
are where it's at i gotta let uh cheetah
just got like like a really
good cooking style right here apparently
that [ __ ] they like really good making
movies it's like the women are just i'm
beyonce
like right right right i'm curious um
how how like you you the obvious like i
think when people see you guys
the immediate comparison you guys have
gotten is outcast this whole like since
you guys have come out right
um i think sonically there's some fair
points to that but i also feel like you
know
i feel like you guys are influenced by
so much more than cast
i think it was dope because i remember
go ahead and actually
of course i mean of course man i want to
stink on you that outcast is my favorite
group
ever andre's like my top three ever like
when i went to stankonia and i was
i was like i was but if my 12 year old
self would have seen me
as an outcast with all the plaques and
then the artwork of like the naked girls
from the cds and [ __ ] like
it was amazing but like i'm i know i
can't do that no more man
you can't even have artwork and then cd
work i know it's crazy
do you remember how fire their cd is
always fine
cd where you see the artwork used to be
crazy bro i don't think anyone's ever
had better
cds than outcasts they always had the
naked girls on everywhere yeah you can't
live
atl the atlanteans one was the best
with them this thank you
outcast album uh musically see a lot of
people don't like this
but i say my favorite album by them is
stank on you just because
i like some i like the hits but i also
like some of the experimental stuff
gasoline dreams i
yeah but also i mean i i don't know if
that would be considered the best i
don't think that that means
stink onion was that you guys just like
everybody
like
was the first one i ever heard that was
the first one like i ever really bought
and then i went back and bought
the other one yeah that was still an
honest on atl my dad bought atlas
i remember when he let me hold it i was
probably i had to be i mean
when when state going came out we didn't
feel great so whatever year was i was
like a super little kid
i'm 33 how old are you guys 30. i just
started okay so we're kind of you know i
remember like as a kid like when
when my i had a like a big homie in my
apartment complex who had at aliens
and like when i saw the cd i was like oh
[ __ ] it's a naked girl exactly
i i remember stealing my dads and like
just having it in my room or something
like
playing the music you think you're doing
something real wrong
i don't know what to do i just really
loved it still and then my mom came and
found it she was like what's this i like
his dad cd
which it was but right at that man
yo i heard i heard you guys you know um
you guys have a lot of respect for snoop
dogg too
yeah yeah you know i just had a
conversation um
with uh bdot from rap radar and uh we
were we're kind of
we're doing like a year-end uh wrap-up
for 2020 and um
i was we're talking about who's the
who's been the biggest rappers
ever at their peak and i said it's um at
just at their peak i'm not saying like
over the span of their career but just
like you know their peak
i think it's snooping 50. i'm gonna say
550 is gonna be my turn
i just think it's 50 and snoop i don't
know if i don't know i mean
i mean what kind of beard no but i mean
like outcast had a run
and obviously you know if you think but
if you think of peak outcast it was love
below and speaker box
it was amazing i don't no no but i don't
disagree with you
of course they won best album of the
year at the grammys is diamond
but they were kind of like it was two
separate albums
like their peak was kind of like andre
solo album and then
speaker box that had some [ __ ] with it
it was like
to me like i'm talking about like first
like
yo snoop dogg was on vibe he had the
murder case
like he just came off the chronic doggy
style like
that that's the difference right there
because like
50. album with that speedway
below even if you count it as one thing
it still was more about the music and
about the art than anything else which
is a great way to pete right
but we fit the answer it's about them
it's about them their characters
story like 50 just got shot nine times i
remember [ __ ] telling me that
in school i was a little kid like what
happened to this [ __ ] right
oh five nine times
and he had a [ __ ] video game that was
fire on xbox
that's what i'm saying yeah it's uh
to me it's either 50 or snoop but but
yeah i think it's i think it's probably
like if you were if
i had if you put a gun in my head i
would probably say 50. i mean you say m2
see m possibly but you know impossible
now we talked about your guys's favorite
cast albums but just in general
hip-hop if you guys had to go to an
island with five rap albums
specifically yeah you know five yeah
some
you know some people be like you know
pink floyd or you know no no five rap
albums
you're on an island for a year and you
can only listen to five rap albums
um i'm gonna take a reason put that off
break whoo just because it i
i never explained that's hope i'm gonna
go with the blueprint okay
i need i need that i like reasons i like
i like i like young hoe i like
i like when he's i like this then i'll
go always speak about love below
that's one count of one i like that
that's a loophole
good that's i like that then i'm gonna
go with
um this educational line here this
education will be my second one
okay we gotta let her wrap up
[Music]
i'm gonna go with i'm trying to figure
out which hot boys album i want one of
them hot boys
warfare i think it's good i think i'll
be guerrilla i don't know i think it
might be gravel i think i might be the
one before that what would the one
before that
on there man registration okay just
because it's super long
the longest one like registration is my
favorite connie album
i don't think it's the best kanye album
it's my favorite i'll eat it i'll take
late registration
um so you're gonna take a guerrilla
warfare yeah
i think you you got you got two more
yeah i got two more
i got whole lauren kanye me i think you
and i
have the same favorite jay-z album in
the same favor kanye album yeah i
i well i flipped like a four for that
kanye one but i did one of my favorites
every now and then i do be on that dart
twisted of course
that's the other one he's the top one
and honestly shout out to jesus i think
he's just his age
i think it's i think it's aged so well
man
you know the only person i heard say
that i got listen to it now when it
first came out i was like i remember
myself you know you know that holds me
where he looked like he trying to [ __ ]
that with me like all right everybody
like this [ __ ] i'm gonna just try to
keep bumping me
not everybody liked it he didn't stick
with me like his other words it's his
most polar
polarizing album for sure dirty sprite
too
yo yo shout out to the future
so that's my number four ds2 so good bro
it is it's funny because when we when we
got in atlanta um
i was just being like a typical you know
tourist or i'm like okay i got to play
dirty sprite too and
atlanta you got to play that yeah i
played that and thug motivation
and i was like this is this feels right
i'm in atlanta for the first time
season two will be my last one okay
yeah who do you think if you guys had to
say who's more influential
thug or future future future uh i'll say
future just because a lot of these
around the world trying to be future
everybody say [ __ ] can't beat them
so far but [ __ ] gonna try to be future
[ __ ] can't be future either but
they're gonna try
the only thing [ __ ] will never try to
wear a dress like that
like [ __ ]
they come from the world so they like
they come close and they still do their
own thing
you know what i'm saying but it's like
nobody from outside of atlanta has tried
that
people from outside of atlanta have
tried to be future you know saying
designer the whole thing i ain't saying
you don't say nothing wrong
he did but no no but he sounded i mean
let's be honest he had a whole bunch of
future influence but you can't
the influence of my dog like say what
you want about you writing your song but
like you can't deny influence
yeah and then not even his own fault
because if you talk to him like that's
just his voice no that's what that [ __ ]
is
saying ain't nothing wrong with it but
it you can't have an influence of like
the style of
everyone thought panda was future's
record when it first came out it was
like this new future [ __ ]
what is it crazy it's not future yeah oh
[ __ ] dudes from new york
new york yeah i think um i think future
kind of kind of um you know
with just making like melodies first
um you know obviously you can go back to
um
you know obviously drake you know was so
far gone but i fee
i feel like what future did with
melodies and hip hop it's just
his his fingerprints are all over
everything right now
like everybody like roddy rich like post
malone
like all these people who are like the
biggest rappers in the world like you
guys you gotta pay tribute the future
bro
and he just had more time in the game
too if you want to go a future verse up
you just gotta give it to him from
seniorities this guy's got a dungeon
family tattoo on his forearms
like come on man you got a little more
time again i remember listening to
future records on like
on like me taking like long wire type
[ __ ] in like eighth and ninth grade
[Music]
we've been around to see that [ __ ] be
like a lot of things you know what i'm
saying what do you
feel like the camaraderie is like in
atlanta because you know from an
outsider's perspective
um from being like you know from the
west coast you know we always look at
atlanta as like the example
of uh like networking there's so much
unity
yeah and and now mind you i also realize
that there's a lot of beef and [ __ ] out
here but for the most part
when more people come in yeah but i feel
like just in general the perspective of
atlanta
is like there is some real unity out
there because he said atlanta man
you know saying like as long as atlanta
went like you seen
gucci and jeezy bro like who else gonna
do that
name another beef on the coast [ __ ]
gonna come together
you know what i'm saying but they really
at the end of the day they came together
as men and was like you know what for
the sake of atlanta
for the sake of unity for the sake of
seeing everybody prosper but don't
squash it like that's atlanta man i keep
[ __ ] about we talking about future
the influence gucci really was the
father about that situation
well i think gucci don't get enough i
think he's probably the greatest god
father uh he might be grandfathered yes
yes ever i think gucci is probably the
greatest hip-hop history on this planet
for the show
think about all the people he could have
signed mm-hmm
like he could have had the migos you
know what i mean he could like all these
people who could have been
his artist and they still come from his
dojo you know for sure
for sure he's styling martial arts so
like that [ __ ] that gucci one
and like that's he's just like a perfect
example of what atlanta is like you
gotta always be looking out for your
young [ __ ]
and and and it's pointing them in a
direction to get some money for
themselves you know what i'm saying like
not just
not just trying to satisfy him you know
he's like look did what i did did what
you could do
and you're always looking for somebody
else like that is there a big um
do you feel like there's a disconnect
from like the younger generation of
atlanta hip-hop and like
you know there's that clip of um of
young thug uh talking about
andre um do you think there's like a con
like a disconnect
between the older generation um and the
and the generation that's coming up now
now i just feel like
we just so focused on paving our own way
you know what i'm saying even like they
was back then
of course of course everybody back then
was like man hey
this this the first time atlanta is
being i'm going to matter
we're paving our way from from dungeon
family to tlc to jermaine dupree you
know yeah
like it was it was a risk everest in the
face like that was like the first major
record label here so they paving their
way
come to our generation you know what i'm
saying you got qc you got
slack you got the slime boys you got
gucci and everything that he doing you
know what i'm saying
we paving our way you know what i'm
saying so it's like i don't think it's
so much as disrespect
but i was just like we just focused in
we appreciate what they did
but number one we focus and we're
trailblazing you know that's facts
that's facts um any you guys care to
spill any uh any jayco album tea you
know i mean we're supposed to get the
fall off
we got it oh do we know when it's
dropping i mean the fall was here
everything's driving next week okay next
week so we got two weeks
lined up it's on the dsps and everything
it's already uploaded we're ready to go
just gonna just come out of nowhere just
a he yo
that's that's i mean there's a link away
um
have you got you know somebody who i i
think uh you know one of my favorite
artists and one of my good friends in
atlanta is killer mike have you guys got
a chance to link with him and
uh and work with him at all not working
on music but we definitely met him a
couple times
it would be nice to do some music
because i'm like that's the first cd i
ever purchased my own money monster
monster
wow when i was a kid that's not even on
spotify that's crazy i never even
thought
i haven't even tried to listen to it
since
wow i feel like what he what him and
like what run the jewels are doing it's
just very original and i feel like with
you guys you guys are also original in
your own way
and i feel like it'd be it'd be a crazy
uh it'd be crazy
if you guys would be crazy i i i ain't
studied them like i should i still be
like focused on the mic part but i got
no mike's [ __ ] that he's working on some
[ __ ] right now he played me like 25
songs the other night and jesus [ __ ]
christ
that's fine what about psy the prince we
we missed our highlight maybe like
once years ago bro i mean he never
didn't know what's happening
he's also from a different side of town
that's too so it ain't been like no
pressure
mm-hmm got you got you got your chicken
from the west side but also
i ain't never didn't know besides that
would be interesting hey man i'm just
thinking like who's a [ __ ]
you guys can wrap your asses off he
could wrap his ass off like
you know that might be too much [ __ ]
we might need something too much bars
he might need some more [ __ ] right
right
yo that's crazy um so we're gonna get
out hopefully by the summertime
um the single is out uh with wale
yo and i think you know can we talk
about just wale real quick because i
feel like we don't get wale of his
flowers in there man his flowers put
that man put the dna who came my man
bouquet gotta do it because that man
been going strong for ten plus
kids for yeah for i mean i mean he he
was like
leader of the blog era like he was in
the blog
i remember yes me too gotta respect the
man lenny he's got to respect what he's
done
you know what i'm saying yeah i feel
like we just got to give some respect to
wildlife because i feel like when we
talk about like the grades of you know i
feel like you know
he don't get mentioned enough wales had
a consistent crazy career
career is unmatched you know like like a
hell of a career bro
and then cool jerry seinfeld you got
songs
you guys [ __ ] with seinfeld i do like i
like we like curves i'm gonna say i'm a
curve guy
hey holla at me larry dave yo i always
tell everybody the only person i'll
probably
[ __ ] like if i ever met i'd like
really stand out like a [ __ ] it would
be larry david
if i met larry david i'd be beside
myself and you know he would be so
annoyed
what the [ __ ] yo listen bro i know you
don't want to take this picture i know
you hate everything about this moment i
know you hate it i love it
i love it and i know you you know let me
just get this selfie bro
so i'll i'll be kicking it with him two
minutes if i if he live around come with
me in l.a i would literally be jogging
every day
yo let me ask you guys this because with
some of your guys's artwork and visuals
and [ __ ]
very very trippy [ __ ] do you guys
partake in any uh any uh psycho
psychedelics at all we definitely have
in life yeah think about this man we
you know i'm saying you ever seen my
manager brought up today this video we
did a long time ago called 16 albinos in
the swats
we was doing like psychedelics in the
desert in that video so
years ago mushrooms you guys ever [ __ ]
with dmt
never did dmt uh i don't i never did dmt
because it looked like crack number one
and then
two uh you got a free base set yeah you
gotta say it look like crack and then
they be saying
uh it's like the feeling you get when
you born in you die and i feel like
that's special so i'm just let that
happen you know
you know what's crazy mike tyson does it
like once a month i know a lot of people
that do it too much but
they all be burnt out like my attention
also cannot kill that if you need to
come to it so like
that's cool yeah i've been that's that's
the one thing that i haven't tried that
i like i just want to try everything
uh lsd nah only mushrooms lsd is pretty
fun it's very clean feeling too you just
be like
and then the other thing people do is
like i got a homie that'll go out to
like he goes to um costa rica
and he does ayahuasca like shaman like
that's like some powerful [ __ ] that's
like yeah he says it's a tight daddy
version yeah he's like i i
did 30 years of therapy in a whole in
two days i believe that
yeah damn he was like i might have to
get a little i come back he did that
[ __ ]
and this guy he was his wife no my man
was
he he smoked cigarettes his whole life
he had a cocaine problem
he was a horrible gambler just got just
my guy he had a lot of vices
he did that [ __ ] hasn't touched a drug a
cigarette nothing since
i did it all it's crazy that's awesome
yeah i think i think like i think the
one thing that psychedelics do is just
kind of expand your mind to what's
already there
like what if you on that side of not
touching drugs and you do you probably
go to the other side of like cocaine and
cigarettes and stuff
now what i'm saying i want nothing to do
with that guy
yeah i think um i think that it just it
kind of expands your mind to what's
already there that we just you know what
i mean i do feel like there's
there's there's there is stuff that we
don't see that is this
i'm the president 100 i think this alien
shit's about to pop off to give it a
buck
if i was an alien and i was looking down
at this [ __ ] i would not come this way
i'd be like what for what oh wait till
we burn each other out and then just
take it over like
i play you smart enough to get across
the universe then you should be smart
enough to see that that's a [ __ ] show
you could be
i'm awaiting this yeah yeah like just
wait for that to burn all up
they might need to come down here to
humble all of us though i mean if we
can't
buy this [ __ ] then it ain't gonna happen
bro right by this world today
bro the capital the capital [ __ ] is
crazy the capital the kovic the ward
everything if the world today can't
humble you and get you in a place of
focus and love
then what's going what we need yep
that's facts man well look um
earth gang i appreciate you guys for uh
tapping in um
hopefully we get albums sooner than
later sooner sooner
sooner and um uh the new single is out
go support it go
you know go run that [ __ ] up on at your
radio stations and uh and call in and
get on their nerves bro you trying to do
like they used to do back in the day
you know what i'm saying but they used
to call in and be like plugging in you
know the problem is though
most radio stations well not in atlanta
obviously but a lot of places the
stations
all the all the people are doing the
shows from home yes but no one's there
to answer the [ __ ] calls
you gotta throw rocks at the window you
just gotta tweet tweet the radio
stations
and no keep it a little secret all your
fans
if you're in the car and you hear the
record shazam it
yeah oh yeah because because if you know
it anyway
because radio stations look at the
shazams
and they use that [ __ ] to try to see so
all the fans all the earth gang fans
play it in your car and then shazam the
[ __ ]
what is this [ __ ] because it'll help it
it'll happen at that radio that's it
everybody
great way to bootleg boom boom boom
earth game appreciate y'all for checking
in